Gravitational potential energy--well, the energy that's somehow stored in gravity.
Well, what do I mean by that--well, we talked earlier about lifting a bucket of mass m
up to a distance--let's call it h for height.
Now, last time we actually assigned some values to m and to h and of course,
we used g the acceleration to gravity to calculate this work that we had to do.
This time we're going to leave our answer in terms of variables and so what I want to know
is how much work do you do and that's you--not how much work does gravity do
and not how much is the total work--how much do you do when
you lift an object of mass m by a distance of h.
I've given you four options. Try and choose the best one.